my name is Blake Richards I'm a
neuroscientist and artificial
intelligence researcher I'm an assistant
professor at McGill University my
research is about trying to uncover
general principles of intelligence that
apply equally to both machines and
people the kinds of things that we study
are for example you know what do you
actually use your memory for and how
does your brain decide what to remember
and what to forget that's actually a
really fundamental principle to your own
intelligence and your own understanding
of the world you can imagine that if you
were able to build a computer system
that remembered in the way that humans
do it would be just that much more
intuitive and potentially able to take
on human roles in society as opposed to
just being some kind of alien black box
that we stick stuff on see far has had a
big impact on my direction as a
researcher because what it really allows
us to do as researchers is to explore
the edges of our knowledge but also
because a big part of their mission is
that you have to come and talk to other
researchers from other disciplines you
have to get other perspectives come to
lots of meetings think about things in
ways that you hadn't thought about
before and interact with people you
wouldn't normally interact with
[Music]
you